now Senator Josh Hawley represents
Missouri and the U.S Senate and he joins
us now
thanks for joining us Senator Hawley
you've talked about in a tweet recently
about how it's time for a change in the
GOP that it's time for new leadership in
the Republican party and having served
in Congress for eight years I know how
much pressure there is for members of
both parties to follow leadership go and
lockstep vote party line I think that's
really there's a lot of different issues
but what kind of leadership do you
envision for this new Republican party
that that gives people the freedom and
Independence to actually vote their
conscience
well we need good strong independent
leadership that actually listens to
voters and doesn't just listen to the
Washington lobbyists and I'll just tell
you when it comes to the GOP the
Washington republicanism that cares more
about Wall Street than it does about
working people it's time for that to
come to an end the Washington
republicanism that's all about
Adventures abroad the neoconservatism of
these Global Wars not focused on working
people in this country it needs to come
to an end I think what voters are asking
us to do is pretty clear secure our
streets you know let's put new cops on
the street 100 000 of them secure the
borders stop the indoctrination of our
children and bring jobs back to this
country it used to be you could support
a family on one good wage you can't do
that anymore in this country because of
the ruinous trade policies that
unfortunately both parties have
supported that has got to come to an end
Republicans have got to be the party of
working people and working class culture
that's what we're fighting for
yeah Senator Hawley I think when we look
at how many people didn't even show up
to vote at all on this last election day
I think that alone sends a really strong
message that we're not hearing any the
pundits address which is people don't
have trust that they actually have
public servants there in Washington who
are fighting for them not for the party
but for them to address some of these
challenges that you're talking about
yeah exactly if you look at who didn't
show up Tulsa you've got Independents
who don't like Joe Biden and they voted
for President Obama back in the day they
voted for President Trump but they
looked at the options this year and
they're like nah I don't like Biden at
all I don't like the Democrats but I
don't trust the Republicans why because
the Republicans weren't offering
anything they weren't saying we're going
to secure the Border they weren't saying
we're going to put cops on the street
we've got to go out there and make that
case we need new leadership in the
Republican party in Washington this is
why I will not support Mitch McConnell
for leader we need new leadership but we
also need real convictions that's what
we've got to be about going forward
thanks so much for joining us Senator
Hawley thank you subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube channel to catch our
nightly opens stories that are changing
the world and changing your life from
Tucker Carlson tonight